KURT ENZINGER: Hey, everyone.
Welcome to "Cloud OnAir," live
webinars from Google Cloud.
We've been hosting
these webinars
every Tuesday this February.
My name's Kurt Enzinger, and
I am a Google Cloud specialist
that specializes in our
productivity and collaboration
tools.
This afternoon, I'm going to
be spending some time talking
with you about different
tips and tricks
to get the most out of G Suite.
You can ask questions
anytime using the platform,
and we have Googlers standing
on by to help answer them.
Sound good?
All right.
So the first stop in
our tour today, we're
going to be talking about Gmail.
As you are all aware, Gmail
is a pretty good application.
And you're probably pretty
familiar with how to use it.
But the first thing that
I'm going to show you
is the Search feature.
So I think you all are
familiar with the fact
that you can type
in a search term
or you can type in an
email and spend time
looking through all of those.
But what I want to
do is sort of uplevel
your ability to do
Google searches.
So we're going to be working in
a domain today called Onsited.
And in this domain, I've
subscribed to a lot of rock
climbing and mountaineering
different newsletters.
So let's say we're going to
look for a term called "belay."
We've been able to pull up all
these different emails that
have "belay"
associated with them,
but I need to do a little
bit more searching.
I want to dig in a
little bit on this.
If we come over here, this
is what we call our Advanced
Search options.
We can click down
into Advanced Search,
and we see a whole
other interface of ways
to get more granular in the type
of searching that we're doing.
First thing that
we'll see is we can
choose the location that we're
going to be doing our search.
We can choose All Mail, Inbox.
In this case, I'm going
to look for Unread Mail.
We have the ability to add a
From field that will tell us
who sent the email,
we have the ability
to search by who the
email was sent to,
as well as keywords
in the subject,
and also keywords
anywhere in the email.
In this case, we brought "belay"
over from our original search.
You can also specify
words that you don't want
to be included in the message.
So for example, we don't want to
talk about ice climbing today.
So we're going to remove that.
And then you have
options to determine
if there is attachments or
if there are chats available,
as well as size and date.
So we'll click
through this search
and we've gone from
23 different emails
down to three, which is
much more manageable.
It gives you the ability
to look through and use
your emails more effectively.
Now, that's pretty cool.
But I think that many
of you are probably
going to want to be what we call
power users of Gmail, right?
So here's what I would
recommend that you do if you'd
like to be a Gmail power user.
Open up and go to Google.com
and search for the term
"Gmail search operators."
The first hit is a help article
from our Gmail Help pages.
Bookmark this and then do your
best to try and memorize these.
There's a whole long
list of search operators
that you can use within
Gmail to try and do
more granular searches.
So for example, if we
come back to our inbox,
let's say we want to see any
emails that are unread that
have been sent before
January 1 of this year
and has an attachment.
Just with a simple set
of search operators,
we're able to get very
specific on the types of emails
that we're pulling up to
search for, which gives you
a lot of power in using Gmail.
Awesome.
So we've learned a little
bit about Advanced Search.
We've learned a little bit
about search operators.
But let's think of another
way that we can get organized.
And for that, I want
to share with you
some information about labels.
A label is something that can
be approximated as a folder,
but with some key differences.
Essentially, a label in
Gmail is a different view
of your mail environment
that allows you
to see different sets of data.
Inbox, Starred, Sent
Mail, and Drafts-- those
are all examples
of default labels.
But we have the ability
to create our own labels.
So if you notice,
over here we've
got a lot of messages coming
from "Rock and Ice Magazine."
And since my boss
doesn't really like it
when I'm looking at rock
climbing magazines on the job,
we're going to filter
these out and we're
going to label them so that
they're out of our way.
So we'll create a
new label, and we're
going to call this Rock and Ice.
If you notice here, we can
nest this label underneath
of another one.
We could put it under
Newsletters, Personal, anything
we want.
But just for the
sake of ease, we're
going to create its
own top-level label.
And notice, now, over
here on the right
is a label called Rock and Ice.
If we click on it
right now, there's
no conversations in here.
We haven't labeled anything.
Nothing really has happened yet.
So we'll come back to
our top-level inbox.
And there's a couple
of different ways,
now, that we can
interact with this label.
The first would be
to take a message
and drag it and drop
it over into our label.
That message has
now been archived
and it has the label Rock
and Ice applied to it.
So if we click in there,
here's our Rock and Ice.
We can also go the
other direction.
So let's say we can
select a few of these,
and now we want to label
these with Rock and Ice,
but not archive them.
We take Rock and Ice from our
label set, we drop it on top,
and now they're all
labeled Rock and Ice.
The interesting
thing about these--
now, if you click
on one of these
and into one of these emails,
you can see up at the top
that it has the
label Rock and Ice
and it also has the
label Inbox because it
lives in both of those worlds.
To make labels even
more useful, we
can actually adjust the color.
This is going to
help it stand out
and make it easier
for you to see.
So in this case, we'll turn
this label into bright orange.
There it is-- orange up there.
It's orange down here.
And if we come back
into our inbox,
here are all the Rock
and Ice labeled items.
That's all well and good.
I've taught you how to create a
label, how to change the color,
how to drag and drop things.
But you probably don't want
to spend your entire day
dragging and dropping emails
back and forth, right?
Well, good news-- we're
going to use something
called a filter to try and
help automate this process.
A filter is going to
start at the same place
that the Advanced Search does.
And in this case, we're
going to filter out
the emails that have the
words "Rock and Ice"--
so just the words "Rock
and Ice" and nothing else.
So we're going to
put in a quotation.
We'll type "Rock and
Ice," close quotation.
This is going to
ensure that we're
looking for just
that phrase and not
for any email that
has the word "Rock"
or any email that has the
word "Ice" because that
could complicate things a bit.
What we'll do from here,
before I create the filter,
is I actually just go through
with the search and take a look
and see to make
sure that I'm not
picking up anything unusual.
Everything looks good.
So we'll come back
in and we're going
to create a filter
with this search.
Now that we're in the
filter options here,
there's a lot of things
that we can do with it.
We can skip the inbox,
which we'll do in this case.
You can mark it as read so
that you don't even have
to realize that it came in.
I want to read it at some
point, so I'll leave it.
You can star it.
You can apply the label.
That's what we're
going to do today.
We're going to apply
the label Rock and Ice.
Then you can do things
like forward it,
delete it, send it to
spam, make sure it's always
marked important, all
kinds of good stuff there.
And you would hit
Create the Filter.
Now, once we hit Create
Filter, any new email
that matches this search
will apply these rules.
It will skip the
inbox it, it will
apply the label Rock and Ice,
and it will be good to go.
But what about all
these existing ones
that are already there?
I can just simply check
this box right here, Also
Apply Filter to
Matching Conversations,
we create the filter,
and now all of those
are filtered out
into Rock and Ice.
Nice and easy, right?
Gives you an automatic
way to manage your inbox,
to organize your labels, and
we've also learned a little bit
about how to do some searching.
Awesome.
Well, the next thing
that we want to do,
now that we've talked
about ways that you
can sort of automatically
organize your emails,
I like to spend time with
our customers telling them
about how to visually
organize your inbox.
There's a lot of
different ways to do that.
The first thing that
I like to show people
is turning on and off
Conversation View.
I've been a Gmail user since
it was in beta many, many years
ago, so I love
Conversation View.
But it's what I would
call a polarizing setting.
Either you love
it or you hate it,
and I want to give
you the ability
to turn it on and off
depending on what suits you.
A conversation in Google,
just for those of you
that may not be
aware, is essentially
where we take messages that
are related together, usually
by subject line, and we
bundle them together.
So here, at the top, is an
example of a conversation.
It might be a little
confusing because I
had the conversation with myself
for demonstration purposes,
but we can click
into here and we
can see that there are
three different messages.
First is the message that
I sent, then a reply,
and then another reply there.
If you want to debundle these so
that they don't exist together,
you simply come
into your Settings
and you go into Settings again.
Now, at the top, you'll notice
there are a number of tabs
for your settings.
This one's going to live
in the General area.
About one third of the way
down is Conversation View.
You turn Conversation View off.
And then this is key.
When you're changing
your settings in Gmail,
make sure that you save changes.
Awesome.
So now you can see
that that conversation
bundle has been debundled and
now it's two separate emails.
So if you're not a fan
of Conversation View,
you're welcome, I just
totally changed your life.
The next thing that I
like to show customers
is something called
the Preview Pane.
So a lot of people have
lived in other mail clients
where they have
the ability to see
their inbox on one
side and a preview
of the email on the other side.
So we can do that in Gmail too.
If we come to Settings, we're
going to go to a new tab now,
and this tab is called the Labs.
Labs are experimental features
that you can enable for Gmail.
These labs are going
to be controlled
by your administrator.
So not all of them that
I'm showing you here
may be available.
But that's going to be up
to your admin to figure out.
There's a lot of really
great ones in here--
canned responses, custom
keyboard shortcuts.
But the one that I want to
show you is the Preview Pane.
Again, click on Enable.
Don't forget to
save your changes.
And it's going to
refresh our inbox for us.
It looks the same right
now, but notice we
have this new button up here.
This is where we
control our preview.
So we can choose what type
of split we want to use.
I tend to like the
vertical split.
And now we have the ability
to preview these messages
without losing our inbox.
You can simply
click on your email
and there it is on
the right side panel.
Pretty good stuff, right?
The last thing that
I like to show people
in terms of physically
organizing your inbox
is what I call Priority Inbox.
So if we come back to our
settings, within Inbox,
there's something
called an Inbox Type.
Default Inbox Type is simply
where your inbox will organize
things in chronological order.
The most recent email
that comes in sits on top.
But there's other ways
that you can do that.
You can do Important first
where important emails surface
to the top.
You can do Unread first where
any emails that you haven't
read yet surface to the top.
Starred First-- similarly,
anything that has a star.
I like to do what's
called the Priority Inbox.
This is how I use
my personal Gmail
and how I use my
work G Suite account.
Priority Inbox lets you have
multiple sections as well
as the ability to change and
prioritize those as needed.
So first will come important and
unread, then will come starred.
We can even add
labels in here too.
So we're going to add a section.
If we come into More Options,
here's our Rock and Ice,
and then everything else.
Again, we'll save our changes.
And notice that things
have changed a little bit.
Up here is Important and Unread.
A quick note about
importance-- importance
is a concept in Gmail that
is a learning algorithm.
As you mark things
important or not important,
based off of things
like who sent
the email, the
content of the email,
who's receiving the email,
it will automatically
determine what you might
think is important.
So you can train your algorithm
by marking things on and off
and it will get
better over time.
Here-- down here is what
we have for starred,
then we've got our Rock and Ice.
And you can collapse
these as needed.
And here is everything else.
The Priority Inbox
is my favorite way
to manage my inbox.
It gives me the ability
to surface the things that
are important and unread first.
Then I use stars as
similar to a to-do list.
And then everything
else is stuff
that I don't think is really
that important anymore.
Excellent.
Now, couple more things
to show you in Gmail--
the first one is actually my
favorite setting in Gmail.
It's called Undo Send.
Let's say we're going
to compose a message
and we're sending a
message to Albert Einstein,
because I work with him,
and we're going to say,
"Please review
this information."
I'm really excited.
I'm sending Albert
Einstein some info,
so I'm going to say, "Hi, Bert.
Please take a look below
and give me your thoughts."
But what happens when
I get too excited
and I accidentally just send
it without finishing the email?
Have you guys ever done that?
You hit Send and,
uh oh what do I do?
I've actually got this
Undo Send button right here
where I can click Undo.
And I get my email back
and I have the ability
to finish it, slow down a
little bit, proofread it,
and then I can
send it out again.
In order to turn on Undo
Send, you come into Settings.
Under the General tab,
about four or five
down, we've got Undo Send.
You enable that and you get to
choose the cancellation period.
I choose 30 seconds
because sometimes I
get a little bit
confused and don't
realize that I messed it up.
But this is one of my
favorite, favorite settings,
and it has saved me more
times than I can count.
The last thing that
I'm going to show you
about Gmail before we move on
is what we call Gmail shortcuts.
So like I said, a
lot of you probably
want to be Gmail power users.
If you hit Shift
and question mark,
it's going to pull up all
the different shortcuts
that you can use to interact
with the Gmail interface.
The idea behind this
is the less time
you spend grabbing for your
mouse and looking around
and things like that, the less
context switching that you do,
the faster you're going
to be at composing emails,
at being productive, right?
So there's a lot of them there.
You'll learn them over time.
But for example, if
we want to take a look
at our starred messages,
we can have simply type GS
and it will automatically
pull up our starred messages.
If we want to look
at our labels,
we can type GL and choose
our Rock and Ice label.
And here we are.
If we want to go
back to our inbox,
we can type G and I.
There's our inbox.
And then if you wanted
to compose a new message,
you simply type D, and there it
does-- it automatically brings
up a new message for you.
Again, the idea is we're
going to take seconds off
of each task so that
those seconds add up
to minutes throughout
the week, which
adds up to hours throughout
the months, so on and so forth.
Awesome.
So to review, in Gmail,
we've learned a little bit
about searching,
both advanced as well
as super advanced with
the search operators.
We've learned about labels,
we've learned about filtering,
and then we've learned about
how to visually organize
your inbox in different ways.
But I don't know about you.
My life is controlled by my
calendar, not by my inbox.
So if it doesn't exist on
my calendar, it's not real.
It's not in my head.
So let's move over
to Calendar and look
at some of the cool
things we can do here.
This right here is
actually called the waffle.
So you select the waffle and
this gives you the opportunity
to choose a new application.
For those of you that are G
Suite customers or use Gmail
in your personal life, you've
probably seen the new Calendar
interface.
But if you haven't,
that's all right.
Welcome to the new
Calendar interface.
We'll start in here the same
place that we started in Gmail,
and that's searching.
You can, again, search by terms.
But let's take a look at
the Advanced Search options.
This gives you a lot
of really good ways
to look through your events
that are much more powerful.
So we can look at
different calendars,
we can type in keywords,
we can select organizers
or participants, we can
choose location or room,
we can exclude keywords,
and then also the dates.
Again, the idea
is to make it easy
for you to find what
you're looking for.
Now, the next thing I'm going to
show you is pretty interesting.
I'm sure you're all
aware of how to view
a calendar of your coworker.
You simply come into here, you
can type in your coworker's
name, select it, and now we
can see that person's calendar
overlaid with mine.
But there's something
called Public Calendars
that are pretty interesting.
If you click on the plus
and Add Other Calendars,
you can browse
calendars of interest.
This is going to
give us a number
of religious and
regional holidays,
a very long list of
different regional holidays.
So if you're working
with a particular region
very frequently, you can be
up to date on their holidays.
If you're a sports fan, it also
has public sports calendars.
I used to live in Chicago,
so we can come into Hockey,
take a look at the NHL,
select the Blackhawks,
and we've added
that calendar now.
I can scroll down
and I can see here
are all the Blackhawks events.
Pretty cool, right?
Awesome.
The next thing that
I'd like to show you
is what's called
appointment slots.
Imagine tomorrow I'm
going to be meeting
with a large number of
customers-- six, seven,
eight customers.
And instead of emailing each
one individually and trying
to coordinate all the
different times that
are possible for me
to meet with them,
I'm going to create
an appointment slot,
send everybody one link,
and let them determine
when there is availability.
So to do that, we're
going to drag and drop.
We'll do our appointments
tomorrow from 8:00 to noon.
We're going to call this
"Meetings with Kurt."
And up here, we choose
Appointment Slots.
The next thing
that we have to do
is determine what our
duration is going to be.
We're going to make
30-minute meetings.
And we'll save this.
Now, instead of me
having to coordinate
with all these
people, I can simply
click on this Calendar's
Appointment Page,
copy the link, and then send
that link to a customer.
If we were to-- this
is another environment
that I have-- if we were
to put this in and give it
to the customer, it's actually
going to show a calendar
interface where it overlays
their calendar with all
of these open appointments.
And in order for that person
to schedule a meeting with me,
they simply have to click on
one, fill out the information,
and save it.
That appointment's been booked.
And if we go and look back
at my original calendar,
we should have a new
appointment right here
that we just scheduled.
A really simple and
easy way for you
to minimize the amount
of time that you're
doing coordinating and shuffling
times and all of that--
just simply with
calendar appointments.
Next couple of things
I want to show you
are small, but powerful things.
One is within the
new Calendar, you
have the ability to
restore deleted events
in a very easy way.
Let's say I've got a
proposal meeting tomorrow
and I accidentally delete it
thinking it was something else.
Not a problem-- you simply come
up to the Settings, into Trash,
and here I can select
and restore this event.
And if we come back,
in just a moment
it should be restored--
nice and simple.
The next one is what I
call invisible events.
Imagine on Thursday
morning I'm going
to go rock climbing
for the morning
instead of coming
into the office.
I don't want my boss to know
that I'm out rock climbing,
but I also don't want him to see
that "Do Not Schedule" block,
right?
So we'll call this
"Rock Climbing."
And we're going to
come into More Options.
If I mark it as
Private, it'll still
show up on my
calendar as an event,
but nobody can see the details.
But if I mark it as Private
and I change my status to Free,
then it won't show up on
anybody else's calendar,
and I'll be the only
one that can see it,
effectively making it
an invisible event.
Pretty good stuff there.
Last two things are new
settings in Calendar
that I think are
worth taking note of.
On the left here, we have
our time for our schedule.
You have the ability to have
a second time zone displayed.
So if we come into our
Settings, under Time Zones,
you can display a
second time zone.
I'm frequently working
with Mountain View where
Google's headquarters
is, so I'm going
to have that be my
second time zone.
Now we come back
and automatically,
as I'm scheduling things,
as I'm building out
my calendar for the
week, I can easily
see what the time
is in Mountain View.
And then another thing
that's really great
is what's called working hours.
So I'm very protective
of my work-life balance.
So within our Settings,
I've set working hours such
that when people try to invite
me from Monday through Friday
outside of the hours
from 9:00 to 6:00 PM,
they'll actually
receive a warning,
and that warning will
say, "Are you sure
you want to schedule
it at this time?
This is outside of
Kurt's working hours."
Pretty good stuff.
Some of you may
not have the luxury
of being able to schedule
those working hours.
But if you do, I
highly recommend it,
although what I've found
is that it hasn't really
kept anybody from scheduling
outside of those hours anyway.
Oh well.
Last thing in Google
Calendar-- similar to how
we have shortcuts in Gmail,
we have a large number
of shortcuts in Google Calendar.
And so with the
press of a button,
you can do things
like change the view,
if we would rather see
a day view versus a week
view versus a month view.
You also have a custom
view, which in this case
I've set to three days.
And you can also
select on the side
and choose your own custom view.
If I wanted to do
a four-day view,
you can select on this
calendar the four-day view,
and then it will maintain
that as you scroll
through different time periods.
Excellent.
We've talked a lot
about Calendar.
We've talked about Gmail.
Let's spend a few minutes
in Google Drive and Docs.
So within Google Drive, there's
a couple of interesting things
to show you.
Again, we have an
Advanced Search feature,
which gives you a lot
of really robust ways
to search through your data.
The next thing is an
extension that I think
everybody should be using.
It's called the Office
Editing for Docs extension.
If you search for that
and pull it up in Chrome,
this gives you the ability
to edit Office docs
in their native format
while in Google--
really highly recommend it
because we recognize here
at Google that
oftentimes you're not
going to be working with
somebody else in Google's
environment, and so you
need to have the ability
to edit those documents.
If we take a look at
a document that is not
a Google formatted
document, you also
have the ability to
do versioning as well.
So within a Google doc--
I'm sure you're aware-- you
can click on Revision History
and see every change
that you've made.
You can do something similar
to that within Google Drive.
So if you select-- this
is a Word document here--
if you select that and
you click on View Details,
you come into Details down
here in the bottom right,
it gives you the ability
to manage versions.
We can see all the different
versions that we've had.
I edited it at 11:11.
And you can see all
the different versions
all the way back to when
it was created in 2014.
This is an old one.
You can upload new versions.
You can also download or delete
particular versions, something
that a lot of people don't
recognize when they're dealing
with other formatted types.
Within Google Drive,
as well, there's
something called Quick Access.
So Quick Access is a
setting that you can turn on
under Suggestions, which will
actually take into account when
you last opened a document, what
things are on your schedule,
and it will automatically
surface the things that it
thinks you're going to
work on most often, which
is a great feature as well.
Excellent.
We've talked a little
bit about versioning.
We've talked a little bit about
how to edit Microsoft documents
in Drive.
Next, let's step
into a Google Sheet
and show you some of the
really cool things that
are coming out for that.
So if we come into our folder
here, I have a new sheet.
It's called Black
Friday Week Sales Data.
So it's from this
past Black Friday.
And what I want to do
is-- well, first of all,
it's a little bit hard to see.
It's not formatted well.
So let's do a little
bit of quick formatting
to make it easier to see.
The first thing that
we're going to do--
we'll select everything.
If we go into Format,
Alternating Colors,
this is a really
quick and easy way
to just add some
color to the document
to make it easier to read.
We can also do something
called freezing.
So if we go into View,
we freeze our first row,
and now, as we scroll
down, the title row
stays with it to
make it easier to see
what all these numbers are.
That's all pretty awesome.
But what I really want
to do is get some insight
from this data.
We have this new
feature called Explore.
The Explore feature
will give us the ability
to do some really
interesting things.
It's powered by some awesome AI.
And the first
thing you'll notice
is that it gives us an automatic
suggestion for a pivot table.
In this case, the pivot
table displays average
of unit price for each item.
Really useful-- if you had
to build that pivot table
on your own, it might
take you some time.
You can simply just
click and add that in.
It also does some
initial analysis--
in this case, cost of
goods versus profit.
And you can scroll
through and see which
ones you find interesting.
And then in order to add it,
you simply click Insert Chart,
and there we go.
With a click of a button, we've
got a Count of Items graph
here--
pretty useful.
But let's say we
want even more data.
We want to learn
even more about it.
If we come back to
our Explore function,
we can actually ask
natural language questions
of this feature and
get answers back.
So let's say we want
to know, what item
has the highest profit margin?
It actually understands
that question as top item
by profit margin,
which in this case
was the watch with a
profit margin of 0.6.
And we can click in even
further and see the query
that it used to
figure that out, which
I'm pretty decent with Google
Sheets, but would have taken me
quite a while to
figure that out.
Awesome.
Another really interesting
thing about Google Sheets
is you have the ability to turn
on notifications in the event
that somebody
edits the document.
So if we come in to
Tools, Notification Rules,
you can choose notify me at
my email address any time
changes are made, and
you can do it either
on a daily digest
or email right away.
We click Save.
And now any time somebody
adds data to this,
I'll be able to recognize
it and see the new data--
pretty good stuff.
So let's review all
that we've seen today.
We've seen quite a bit.
We've talked about Gmail.
We've talked about how to
search and organize your inbox.
We've talked about
Calendar and some
of the cool tricks
with the new Calendar
in order to manage your
days and times, especially
appointment slots.
We've talked about
Google Drive and how
to work with some files
that aren't Google
file types in Google Drive,
both through versioning
as well as through
the extension.
And then we've
talked a little bit
about Google Sheets and some of
the excellent new features that
are coming into Google Sheets
around Explore and formatting
and things along those lines.
So that's everything that I
wanted to show you for the demo
today.
We're going to take
some live questions.
So stay tuned for that and we'll
be back in less than a minute.
All right.
Welcome back, everyone.
Thanks for sticking with us.
We're going to go through
a couple of questions
that came up.
Before I get
started on those, we
noticed that quite a few of
the questions that came in
were about product roadmap.
I just want to give you all
a little bit of a heads up.
If you are asking
about product roadmap
and you're current
customer, please
feel free to reach out to your
Google account manager and they
can help you walk through the
product roadmap for both G
Suite and Google Cloud.
If you're a prospective
customer and you're
interested in learning more
about our product roadmap,
please go and visit
the Google Cloud
blog where we'll make
all public announcements.
Awesome.
So we've got five questions
here that we can potentially
address today.
The first is whether the company
is the ultimate owner of data
for every user in G Suite--
that's absolutely correct.
When you're putting
your data into G Suite,
Google identifies
that you are the owner
of that data and
Google is what's
called a data processor,
meaning that at any time
you have the ability to
remove that data from Google.
We don't use that data
for advertisements.
We don't use that data for
improving our products.
We don't use that
data for selling.
We don't do anything with it.
It's your data.
But thanks for asking.
Regarding Google
Vault-- if I enable
Vault for an organization
and set the retention period
to undefined, if an
employee leaves the company
and I delete his or her
account, can I browse and export
a specific file of this user?
So this is an
interesting question.
For undefined, I
think you probably
meant indefinite,
which means you
would keep that data forever.
But there's a
particular caveat here.
When you're using
Google Vault and you
have a user that
stored data there,
whether it's in a legal
hold or whether it's
in just the normal
retention period, if you
delete that user, that
data is no longer around.
And so what you
want to do-- there's
a couple of different options.
If you're going to
be deleting a user
and you want to
save that data, I
would recommend doing the export
prior to deleting the user.
There are a couple
other options.
And if this is an important
part of the platform for you,
please reach out to your
Google account manager and we
can talk a little bit
more about the details.
All right.
Can we put Google
Drive documents
into labels instead of
putting them in folders?
In that case, what happens
if the folders are shared?
So at this point, the files
that we store in Google Drive
have limited metadata.
You have the ability to look
at the metadata that is there
and add a small description.
But the concept of
labels don't actually
exist at this point
in Google Drive.
So if that's
something that you're
looking for in terms
of functionality,
we have a number of
third-party providers
that can add that
type of functionality.
One would be Powertools.
Another would be AODocs.
Those are both
third-party platforms
that are built on top
of Google Drive that
help you with your sort
of content management, CMS
type of needs.
Can people book
appointments with Calendar
Appointments if they don't
have a Google account?
They can book appointments with
Calendar appointment slots.
The difference being
is that it's not
going to show then an
example of their calendar.
It would just give them the
opportunity to book the slot,
and then they would have to
manage the calendar appointment
in their own calendar.
Finally, the
ever-popular question,
can we turn off Conversation
Mode on mobile or iOS?
And at this point,
it is not possible.
Unfortunately, you're stuck
with Conversation Mode
in your mobile device,
unless, of course,
you choose to use the native iOS
Mail application, in which case
you would need to have access
from your administrator
to do IMAP mapping for
your Gmail account.
Excellent.
Those are all the questions
that we've got for you today.
Thank you very much
for joining us.
Please be sure to
tune in next week
for more information
about Google Cloud.
Appreciate everybody's time.